[Musique]
concert.le diego pour ne pas vous le
savez donc on fait preuve sur toutes les
émissions de télé réalité qui nous offre
chaque jour de jolis moments de freddy
et aujourd'hui on va parler de la
bataille des couples lourd sur tf6 comme
on en avait parlé aussi on a parlé des
marseillais alors concept pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas la bataille des
coupes je le redis ils ont tout pris à
kolontar la plage les candidats les
épreuves sauf le budget les années moi
c'est donc des couples qui s'affrontent
autour d'épreuves et hier on s'est
gentiment moqué d'une épreuve du jeu à
laquelle on ne comprenait rien qui était
pas ouf
aujourd'hui je tenais à m'excuser parce
que je peux vous dire j'ai l'impression
qu'ils nous ont écoutés ils ont mis les
bouchées doubles aujourd'hui regardez ce
hollywood chaque couple à 25 e pour
gagner l'immunité il faut être le
premier à poser les ciseaux dans la
poêle armé d'un bâton copier les hommes
devront franchir un parcours semé
d'embûches
sans casser l'oeuf ensuite ils devront
le jeter et leur femme devra le
rattraper notez que les femmes seront
debout sur une poutre
mais le porteront en plus des lunettes
kaléidoscopique qui troubleront leur
vision attention aussi à emma et anthony
qui ont le pouvoir de friser pendant 20
secondes le couple de leur choix grâce
alors si fait magique
comment je vous le dis je suis super dès
qu'ils ont une valve défaut et c'est pas
mal aimé dans l'épreuve ça peut être
sympa ça rigolait way et on a quoi on a
déjeuné mais qu on a quoi des oeufs
d'élus venus ont fait passer des oufs
mon frère mais qui cette émission alors
ya cette nouvelle épreuve est placé sous
le site vous l'avez vu il nourrit cran
grand la tolérance c'est à dire que pour
gagner les couples devraient faire et
preuve de calme de partage et d'amour
le problème c'est qu'un couple c'est
virgile et chloé en fait eu il ya marqué
tolérance en énorme
j'ai l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas bien
compris les règles je regarde deux bien
maire tremblay croit pas mais il a trop
court jack dromey bloc
la cavale de passer le pont tout cas
c'est un
[Musique]
madame grès
c'est malika est marquée en dénombre
tous les ans
attribution même plaisir les marseillais
bien entendu le concept on prend des
gens on les met dans une maison et on
attend qu'il fasse des trucs débiles et
puis on fouille on touille d'ailleurs
j'ai vu pas gâtés alors que j'adore
c'est vraiment un amour et on l'a
retrouvé notre ami paga en plein débat
alors comment on reconnaît un génie qui
réfléchit ce que pas gaffe pour moi
c'est un génie qu'est-ce qui fait il se
gratte la tête
et comment reconnaît-on un génie du paf
qui réfléchit il se gratte aussi mais
pas la technologie mais le faire
pourquoi c'est maija froch attaque il va
là
la julienne je les adore j'aimerais
qu'on serre est trente secondes sur un
autre c'est une autre star de l'émission
c'est celui voilà qui est tout à droite
c'est julien tonti c'est une des stars
du programme et je sais pas pourquoi
mais à mon avis il a passé plus de temps
julien au salon de tatouage avec à la
bibliothèque
il a un petit peu comme voir moi je suis
content en tout cas que les esprits se
sont calmés
j'avais un peu peur hier sur en se
couchant je vois que tout le monde a un
petit peu mis de l'eau dans son jus
d'orange il ya un truc impressionnant
chez les marseillais c'est leur calme et
a notamment une jeune fille s'appelle à
nice à la meuf elle est une zénitude
alors franchement c'est un truc de ouf
d'ailleurs elle le dit elle même
regardez même dans les conflits je vous
jure on dirait le dalaï lama est
toujours calme et je vous en parlais
hier j'ai une chouchoute ses maiva bas
il va c'est le jackpot des insultes et a
été dans l'ambiance charcuterie donc
elle traiter tout le monde de merguez
aujourd'hui elle est passée en mode
végétarienne avec uniquement des
insultes à base de légumes et de plantes
regarde merci anissa est un mot pour les
marchés et peut-être bah ouais si je
vous ai tout ce qu'il fait bon sauf
celle-là
casse toi qui t'en vas à tête de chou
fleur ok mon retour en france
merci elle de paris elle le cache
elle voulait le cacher je vous le dis
dans les marseillais mais il va ya un
truc à vous les cache absolument c'est
qu'elle était spécialisé dans la
physique physique dont la rive-sud
matières scientifiques quoi match
physique physique quantique
elle connaît très bien physicien je vous
le dis et l on parle hyper bien elle le
connaît à peu près mais elle le connaît
regardez choix un tableau avec un schéma
mathématiques
si un truc dingue stein je sais pas
comment on va faire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était léger